bonjour comme bien souvent le lundi nous
sommes venus dans les coulisses d'une
émission de télévision nous avons choisi
cette semaine l'équipe des chiffres et
des lettres
nous avons profité de notre déplacement
au festival international de monte carlo
pour assister aux heures les plus
chaudes de l'année de cette émission à
savoir la finale des chiffres et des
lettres
dieu sait si armand jammot et fier de
son idée c'était une idée toute simple à
mécanismes de jeu extrêmement rigoureux
et carrés et un succès non-stop depuis
je ne sais combien d'années
armand jammot depuis combien de temps
dure cette émission elles durent elles
durent depuis sept ans est en vérité
elle dure depuis 14 ans même un petit
peu plus de 14 ans parce que j'ai
démarré d'abord avec un seul jeu c'est à
dire le mot le plus long en 66 en
octobre 66 je crois est le seul jeu des
délais de dire le moule que l'on
disputait à cette lettre
et puis cet étui michel de mahler elle a
eu des déprogrammations des
déprogrammations et puis j'ai redémarré
ya sept ans
avec earth a battu m'a demandé de
reprendre le jeu mais en me demandant de
rajouter quelque chose et c'est à ce
moment là j'y pensais d'ailleurs depuis
assez longtemps que j'ai rajouté le
compte est bon
il me semblait que c'était le deuxième
pied de l'émission le matériel culturel
de base
l'alphabet et le vocabulaire les signes
et les symboles de l'arithmétique et
vous connaissez le résultat c'est vrai
il paraît que vous êtes vraiment fier de
cette bonne idée moins cher oui j'ai pas
besoin d'être le tri je savais ce que je
vous rappeler ce que disait francis
blanche il vaut mieux être riche et en
bonne santé que pauvre et malade
bon je pense qu'il vaut mieux avoir une
venir et une mauvaise est d'autant plus
que si ç'avait été une mauvaise idée
on s'attend en train d'en par oui non il
ya longtemps que ça n'existerait plus
dur sera pas en train d'en parler
est ce que vous avez observé une
progression cours de ces six ou sept
années de chiffres et lettres progresse
que les candidats sont les mêmes que les
premiers
il ya une progression première
progression il ya plusieurs progression
la première progression constante
jusqu'à cette année c'est une
augmentation de l'écho ça a démarré
comme ça tout doucement tout doucement
et puis l'écoutent n'a cessé de monter
disons jusqu'à 1979 il s'entraîne
maintenant on est atteint un plafond
bon deuxième peuple deuxième progression
c'est que il ya un rajeunissement des
candidats n'ont pas tiré moins de 2
de téléspectateurs adultes ou du
troisième âge qui nous écoute mais il ya
maintenant arrivant à larges de 2 de la
candidature si vous voulez des com
le jeune de la patelière il y as d'aider
des jeunes gens qui ont presque appris à
lire en regardant les chiffres et des
lettres a appris à compter avec les
chiffres des types qui arrivent
maintenant à large cela candidatures qui
sont des candidats et qui se révèle
particulièrement voyants notamment dans
le comté bombe et dans les locaux aussi
bien sûr mais ils sont beaucoup plus
fort maintenant aux comptes est bon que
ne l'étaient les candidats diam et ont
quatre ou cinq ans vous avez annoncé la
modification à une modification de la
règle du jeu à savoir que vous allez
ajouter une lettre il ajouté parce que
nous pensons que d'abord ça ouvre une
nouvelle tranche 2 de reach abus l'air
nous avons démarré avec cette lettre
sa durée avec cette lettre pendant
c'est en moi et puis ensuite personne
n'a bronché personne n'a protesté quand
nous sommes passés à huile est et
maintenant je pense que on va rajouter
une nouvelle 9e lettre je pense que ça a
pas choqué les habitués des chiffres et
des lettres
ils pourront toujours faire des mots de
saint clet de sylhet de cette lettre
mais peut-être ça va ouvrir une nouvelle
tranche de deux mots et puis ça veut
obliger les spécialistes sutil se sont
créé un système sap et les obliger à
tout recommencer
c'est pour cordy vous dites saines on
leur donnait encore un petit peu de
raisons de se distraire les des
spectateurs regrette une modification
que vous ne portez toujours pas alors
qu'ils attendent pourquoi toujours
exclusivement le petit la commande et
coûteux
c'est une question
c'est une question qu'on se pose aussi
depuis depuis très longtemps il faut
dire que
on était en train de l'évoquer
l'émission
jazz and any 14 ans mon à l'époque quand
on a démarré l'émission il paraissait
assez évident de d'utiliser le
dictionnaire qui était à l'époque disons
qu'ils dominaient et qui était
pratiquement le seul sur le marché il y
en avait d'autres métiers thème inconnue
maintenant c'est plus tout à fait la
même chose il ya le dictionnaire
larousse il ya le petit robert s'est
fait une place sur le marché je mets
juste quelqu'un va sûrement me reprocher
de faire de la publicité et
additionnelles achète et à l'outil ya un
certain nombre de dictionnaires et au
fond disons que c'est un peu l'habitude
et c'est vrai qu'on a reçu énormément de
l'aide de jean loup disant pourquoi
celui-là parce qu'il est vrai qu'il ya
des mots qui ne sont pas dans le petit
larousse qu'on peut trouver dans
d'autres dictionnaires dans ce que je
viens de citer que ce serait trop
compliqué d'avoir fait 13 3 max
favalelli pratiquement 1 dans la chaîne
il faudrait que minc c'est trois paires
d'yeux 3 main droite pour fouiller dans
trois dictionnaires mais c'est peut-être
pas impossible qu'on utilise deux
dictionnaires après tout bertrand
peut-être bien donner un coup de main
mal ça va les lui vous avez aussi
annoncé la création depuis quelques
temps déjà deux clubs des chiffres des
lettres
quel intérêt cela représente pour vous
producteur de cette émission
d'abord c'est super c'est quand même la
consécration d'une émission une émission
qui suscite un tel engouement que des
gens souhaitent prolonger leur plaisir
de jouer à cette émission européenne
souhaite se réunir entre eux pour jouer
à l'émission disons que c'est une forme
de consécration
je préfère ça à des gens qui liront
cette émission la barbe
bon c'est bien que des gens est en vue
de se réunir pour jouer à un autre jeu
ensuite c'est un lien avec le
téléspectateur il ya beaucoup de gens
qui nous écrivent en dix ans
ah je cherche dans ma ville des gens
qu'on joue et on aime bien votre jeu
mais ce n'est pas assez long ça dure que
20 minutes
je voudrais bien trouver des gens qui
jouent aussi bon l'un avec les clubs
avec le journal si le journal reprend
vie pour le moment il est arrêté
bon eh bien il y aura comme ça pour tous
les fanatiques pour tous les amateurs
des chiffres des lettres et bien il y
aura des moyens de rencontrer un moyen
de deux liaisons peut-être et c'est une
sorte de pré sélection aussi les
animateurs de clubs vous vous indiquez
vos candidats non non ça oui peut-être
mais je veux dire il faudra que les
membres des clubs subissent ta sélection
exactement comme n'importe quel des
spectateurs se sentir obligations le
moins du monde pour eux ni de pas
retenir un club ni quelques autres
obligations que ce soit vous ne voulez
pas mélanger non je peut mélanger
d'abord parce que ces soldats est normal
le jeu est ouvert à tout et spectateurs
chaque semaine nous vendredi sur le
studio 4 l'équipe des chiffres et des
lettres enregistre huit émissions chaque
semaine alors qu'est ce qui vous a donné
l'idée de proposer votre candidature
vous aperceviez vous vous en sortiez
bien huilée du jeu que le jeu la
compétition vous êtes inquiet donc je
sais tout vous croyez que quand vous
serez là bas là en face de tout le monde
vous allez perdre un petit peu vos
moyens vous avez vraiment l'impression
vous êtes un habitué
vous êtes calme et vous monsieur z calme
voilà comment madame qui est à côté
souris relativement bon coup
relativement peu vous êtes fort surtout
sur quoi les chiffres les chiffres mais
pas maintenant chose faite
j'aimerais que vous me disiez ce que est
ce que vous saviez que les émissions se
faisait en une seule fois qu'elle était
diffusé parce que très souvent que les
spectateurs ne distingant souhaité in
patrice laffont à la même chemise la
même cravate toute la semaine combien on
a pris nos noms jeu c'est vrai que c'est
comme ça assure lutter toute façon que
les gens plein de promesses peuvent pas
venir tous les jours quoi alors expliqué
un petit peu là où les spectateurs c'est
pour çà l'émission donc vous êtes
convoqué une journée c'est le vendredi
je dis donc toute la journée 68 la
journée oui bon semaine dernière chez
nous le matin matin
assistez la religion enregistre quoi
parce qu on est sympa quand même vous
montre un petit peu les copains sur le
grill et apprend grimés vous regarde
toujours à tva on a une profonde émotion
et pas assez
n'empêche que on doit par un peu ses
moyens non c'est quand même fait une
chanson m'a pas impressionné pas
impressionné tant qu'on n'a pas atteint
deuxième hypothèse et 3 vous n'y arrivez
pas de danse qui coulait
nerveusement
on
vous espérer aller loin vous êtes juste
venu me voir pour vous mesurer à lui
même je crois que c'est un jeu et ma foi
un peu de chance un peu de malchance un
manque de concentration et la chanson
intervient beaucoup oui parce que si
vous avez le malheur de rater un contre
pour que vous avez demandé en fait c'est
votre tour
on le rate et s'adaptent elles la seule
chose que vous allez rater
mais de temps à perdre son service
exactement exactement je vais te plailly
quel est votre rôle au sein de cette
émission
alors avant l'émission je suis chargé de
recevoir le courrier de d'envoyer des
questionnaires qui sont classés par
numéro et par région de faire des
sélections en province et à peu près à
part en province et à paris on en fait à
peu près une par mois de contrôler
toutes ces sélections ce qui est un gros
travail de décider la barre au dessous
de laquelle je ne peux pas accepter les
candidats parce qu'ils sont tellement
forts maintenant j'ai dû monter la barre
et puis également à l'heure de préparer
carrément alors l'émission c'est à dire
il me faut aussi quand sept candidats
puisque on s'évite enregistrement où
chaque fois et de déterminer quel
candidat je vais prendre alors je tire
au hasard dans des dans des dossiers
parmi des candidats sélectionnés et par
région ça ceci pour éviter que malgré
tout le hasard faisant quelques fois pas
très bien les choses je n'ai pas trois
candidats où dix candidats de paris et
aucune province bon on vous voit jamais
on ne voit jamais pendant l'émission et
menant vous assistez à tous les
enregistrons mairie jour là vous faites
pendant l'émission
alors pendant l'émission bien je pense
que je ne sais pas si on me voit ce que
je fais voilà j'ai un conducteur je peux
le montrer il va peut-être éclater un
petit peu parce qu'il est blanc mais
enfin relâché un conducteur que j'ai mis
au point et dès que le tirage au sort a
désigné quel candidat démarre je mets
moi-même 1 2 3 4 comme ça je sais
toujours qui doit jouer et quoi les quoi
servent ces deux petites lettres la
valeur
je vais tout vous expliquer avant ce que
le g7 table assez perfectionné pour
aider patrice qui est préoccupé lui par
les candidats par la marche de
l'émission et pour le dégager de tout
souci d'intendance disant j'ai inventé
ça aussi et voilà alors j'avais ça de
chaque côté normalement alors avant le
jeu c'est comme ça dès que le tirage au
sort a eu lieu si c'est le monsieur qui
est en face de moi c'est à dire à la
gauche de patrice qui joue pour les
chiffres je mets comme ça chiffres tels
que pendant tout le temps du jeu
patrice c'est que c'est le candidat qui
est à sa gauche qui joue et que ce sont
les chiffres et le tour suivant je
remets dans ce sens je mets lettre alors
bon ça l'a peut-être un peu puéril et
facétieux mais c'est très important par
surtout par exemple si l'adversaire
prend le tour du candidat et que malgré
ça ils se trompent
donc il redonne les pois à la première
personne qui a parlé et croyez moi dans
le temps imparti pour l'émission patrice
deviendrais fou à la fin des
enregistrements vous avez
bras droit sur sur le site voilà ça
c'est le dictionnaire oui si vous faire
leur deuil de la jeune oui non je vais
faire un max mais comme max a
quelquefois parle avec les candidats et
que moi je sais que je dois marquer et
tout ça très vite
alors quand je pense à un mot dont je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il soit au dictionnaire
je le regarde dans lectionnaire et je
sais qu'il y ait alors je sais que bon
si max fait un petit peu plus longtemps
à chercher puisqu'il doit donner une
explication en même temps ça me permets
moi de marquer les points max favalelli
les candidats vous ne voyez tout de même
pas pour la première fois lorsqu'ils
sont en direct dans l'émission ou même
en différé non bien sûr
moi je suis les déchets j'ai un peu
chargées de les mettre à leur aise alors
je bavarde avec auparavant j'essaie de
couper de l'est confessé que les mieux
connaître de les détendre ce qui n'est
pas facile parce qu'ils ont une émission
un petit peu à me donner quand il arrive
devant le devant de la caméra alors je
bavarde avec eux tant qu'ils sont à mes
côtés ils ont un sentiment de sécurité
n'a l'heure dès qu'ils passent à côté de
battre ici on dirait un petit peu qu'ils
se rendent à la chaise électrique
et quand vous expliquer ça eh bien je
crois que se tient une chose c'est que
ils ont surtout ils se disent dans l'art
qui sont dans la caméra ce soir
zahia voir tous mes amis tous les
copains tous les les employés quittent
avec moi mes parents vont me voir si
jamais je lâche une bourde et l'homme je
vais être la risée de ces gens là
pendant des années après vous vous
parlez de bourdes faites par les
candidats il vous est jamais arrivé à
vous d'en faire un dieu si vous pensez
bien parce que contrairement à ce que
vous croyez ce cet instrument qui
s'appelle un dictionnaire dont je me
sers pour faire des mots croisés depuis
des années des années je l'oubli au fur
et à mesure que je le feuillette je le
redécouvre tous les jours alors de temps
en temps je commets des erreurs
qui ne sont pas et pardonne à bhl je le
souhaite les qui moi ne remplissent
quand même deux complexes vous faites
tout ce que la présentation de cette
émission met la télévision c'est la
seule chose que j'ai conservée pour deux
raisons d'abord par amitié pour armand
jammot avec qui je travaille depuis des
années et qui m'a toujours bien d'un
coût de ces émissions et puis pour
garder un contact humain avec les gens
justement pour tout de même avoir n'êtes
pas isolé pouvoir justement voir
d'autres
différents parler avec eux c'est
uniquement les deux raisons ce n'est pas
du tout l'amour de monsieur larose qui
me guide
bizarrement bertrand vous avez dit que
vous étiez un littéraire alors que vous
êtes ici le responsable des chiffres
comment en êtes vous arrivé là vous êtes
un ancien candidat
je suis un ancien candidat et puis on
m'a demandé six mois après mon passage
comme candidat de remplacer le précédent
monsieur calculer c'est comme ça qu'un
littéraire s'est retrouvé à faire du
calcul des t-bonds déjà en calcul bien
je sais pas si j'étais bon enfin comme
j'avais été au maximum à l'époque c'est
à dire 12 émissions il fallait être
assez bons en calcul est assez bon en
l'être aussi
qu'est-ce que vous préfériez lorsque
vous étiez joueur je pense que je
préférais je pense que je préférais
peut-être le calcul non pas du tout
parce que j'étais meilleur mais parce
que vu que je suis un littéraire
le calcul était plus nous non plus neuf
et m'amuser davantage bon je faisais je
sais du calcul mental en regardant
l'émission
être monsieur chiffre est ce que c'est
un métier à temps plein pour vous non ce
n'est pas un métier à temps plein vous
faites quoi d'eau j'écris voyez c'est de
la littérature puisque je suis un
littéraire en fait j'écris sur et qu'on
travaille un peu patrice c'est toi le
premier animateur de des chiffres de
l'adp depuis le début c'est un qui
présente l'émission dans cette partie
présentation s'est dit c'est à dire
qu'il faut être là mais que
généralement ahly mateur effet
pourparlers pour interviewer les gens et
puis quand il a fini on ne voit plus les
gens qui répondent avec moi
on voit tout le temps même quand je
parle pas ce qui veut dire que quand je
fais tu feras les jeunes soient
restitués quand je suis là j'en disais
qu'est ce qu'il a l'air sinistre n'ont
elles pas puis quand je fais comme ça
les isv nagl non pas du tout chaud lips
est tout aussi difficile on est à
présent c'est quoi c'est assez pour je
parle pour animer un peu pour julien
sabots à droite la savoie gauche fait
voyelles consonne voyelle console tout
dans les moeurs finalement la limite je
veux dire même jeu le même conseillé aux
téléspectateurs un jour ceux qui
m'aiment pas de mettre un sticker la
place de ma tête je suis toujours être
comme ça ils ne verront plus ma tête
sont plus que ma voix ils verront les
mains qu'est ce que ça change faire
cette émission en direct ici c'est
différent l'ambiance est différent ils
sont plus tendus oui d'abord c'est plus
excitant parce que l'école est d'accord
on retrouve sur très forte dont on prend
vraiment pas partie mon s'intéressent
beaucoup pour masquer pas toujours le
cas lors des enregistrements de la
semaine tout cas les matches entre les
équilibres et en plus pour moi
travailler en public c'est différent et
j'aime pas beaucoup ça et en même temps
ça m'excite c'est pourquoi tu n'aime pas
ça c'est génial ça parce que big ben
pour lui vu que j'avais un super on sait
pas très bien s'il faut qu'on s'adresse
au public en même temps téléspectateurs
il ya il faut trouver un ton qui sera so
2 c'est pas facile mais c'est ce que tu
aimes c'est le direct beaucoup plus que
le public nous a dit que j'y pense pas
vraiment fait un peu ce que j'ai envie
de faire au moins j'ai envie de le faire
ça plaît ça plaît pas et puis c'est pas
très grave
patrice en 8 ou 9 ans d'émission est ce
que tu as souvenir un peu cuisant dans
l'enregistrement
il a dû s'en passer des choses amusantes
sur se serait longuement l'ena qui est
particulier c'est que tant que tu sais
qu'on est
c'est complètement intemporel et nicolas
toujours au moins trois semaines ou un
mois d'avancé donc on peut en rien se
référer n'ya l'actualité des hottes en
est rien mais un jour comme ça pour
faire
parce qu'ils ne restent pas là tu as dû
commencer en lisant le là ça va mal ce
soir j'ai une tête d'enterrement des
spams ou chermat ce maxi enchaîner tout
et c'est tombé malheureusement juste
derrière l'en tellement de monsieur
malraux qui était en direct
je veux dire qu'il ya eu la fin de
l'enterrement avec moi derrière je suis
arrivé que générique pour le là ce soir
j'ai une tête d'enterrement et les gens
vont incendier j'ai eu des versets dit
que c'était un mauvais modèle absolument
alors qu'on adore agit sur l'émission à
moins d'un mois et demi avant la mort
mais ça arrive de temps en temps il ya
eu d'autres saint paul et continue je
vais voir les candidats maintenant
j'aimerais savoir comment vous quand
vous préparé cette émission on a ici les
deux finalistes de monte carlo et je
crois qu'on a aujourd'hui n'ont dans
l'ensemble pas j'irai qu'il ya deux
préparations et une préparation
technique bon mais la technique du jeu
il ya aussi une préparation
psychologique je pense que ce moment
aussi important parce que si je pense
que deux candidats à peu près de la même
valeur
sinon pas le sang froid nécessaire
peuvent craqué au mauvais moment et
c'est ce qui peut faire la différence
le sang-froid et vous en a fallu pour
les directs là c'est plus difficile
qu'en studio à paris
c'est différent mais je pense pas que ce
serait plus difficile c'est plus
difficile parce que les concurrents sont
plus coriaces mais je pense pas que ça
fasse la différence et vous dit que vous
vous prépariez aussi comment dirais-je
pour les chiffres et les lettres comment
faites vous pour les lettres par exemple
les qu'elle m'a dit vous appreniez
dictionnaire c'est vrai mais c'est pas
vrai je pense que c'est matic mans tous
les maux qui font cette et unique dirais
que c'est la question rituelle mais il
est certain que je connais peu plus de
mots que la moyenne des gens qui au
regard sain sans se préparer mais dire
que j'apprends tout par coeur c'est
peut-être beaucoup dire mais je veux
dire par là est ce que vous vous êtes
mis à vous intéresser aux mots du
dictionnaire
dès l'instant qu'ils aient décidé de
jouer à ce jeu où est-ce que déjà de
nature non ça s'est pas passé exactement
comme ça j'ai joué comme tout un chacun
c'est m'amuser je me débrouillais sans
plus enfin pas trop mal et puis voyant
que je pourrais peut-être passer un jour
pour peut être trop minable je suis
préparé plus sérieusement et vous tirez
on dit que vous êtes la star du direct
et l'improvisation vous n'avez rien
préparé jamais jamais mais sincèrement
non totalement ça c'est dire vous avez
eu l'idée de jouer pourquoi parce que ça
marchait bien mais c'est une honte ce
sera apporté un peu d'argent c'est
vraiment la seule raison non elle est
pas cuba qui avait pas de sélection
alors les candidats qui passait était
plutôt moyen par rapport à j'étais pas
trop mal il se trouve que depuis les
sélections il ya des gens comme jean
paul frank shaw philippe inaccessibles
comme en france on arbres pour quelqu'un
qui ne se prépare pas sont des gens
inaccessible
ils connaissent des mots qu'on ne
connaît pas que le commun des mortels
ignore quand vous vous risquez d'en
arriver là a monté car vous n'êtes pas
d'ici valables une semaine à passer au
soleil extraordinaire c'est pas si mal
et vous vous travaillez de quelle façon
je crois que vous avez alors la sienne
oui lorsque j'aurai à dire non pas
tellement intéressant puisque je n'ai
pas la même chose après je suis double
finaliste lui et finalistes alors je
pense que ce serait plutôt lui de nom
mais expliqué moindre ou a320 produits
bien ma façon de m'entraîner et
classique surtout technique vient de
trois consonnes d'entrée et des clés
trois constantes sont sortis on aperçoit
à peu près 1 vous voyez déjà à peu près
où il sortira oui oui c'est une question
d'habitude aussi une question
d'entraînement qui t'a donné que je suis
à dire un du club manceau décidé de
l'être
nous sommes en droit j'ai la possibilité
de m'entraîner tous les vendredis
pendant plusieurs heures
est-ce qui vous a permis d'accéder à ce
niveau 7 le plus fort ce en quoi vous
légèrement un chiffre oui mais j'ai
réussi ces dernières années à combler un
petit peu le retard
j'ai procédé en lettres et vous pensiez
arriver en finale
je pensais
c'est normal c'est un secret espoir que
l'on possède chacun soit mais dès que
j'ai appris le tirage au sort j'ai su
que ce serait très difficile mais je
n'avais pas perdu l'espoir et vous jean
paul
pour moi c'est une technique analogues
enfin je croyais pas de marseille joue
pas en club
non mais je crois que je suis dans le
temps l'innovateur de cette méthode
c'est à dire et puis en plus c'est une
question de trois bébés de probabilités
une construction veut faire un thé je
prends un exemple par exemple cabine si
on veut un t il reste va consonnes
vous avez une chance sur 22 tirs et le
thé faire cabinet pas quand il voulait
un e vous avez une chance sur cinq est
comme si vous avez cabinet sortie de
hays fait vous avez une chance sur 5 x
crois parce que ea ea ne reviendra
peut-être pas forcément à alors c'est
une question de probabilité puis de
technique
j'ai envie d'employer un grand mot vous
allez me dire c'est vrai on chuchote
dans les coulisses ici vous vous dopez
non c'est pas vrai mais sans fin si
c'est vrai c'est vrai à moitié quoi
c'est à dire que depuis les quarts de
finale où j'avais cogiter beaucoup et
j'ai eu peur de craquer nerveusement je
prends un produit pas du tout chimique
un produit naturel pour me renforcer les
nerfs savoir que en plus l'an dernier
j'avais craqué alors je pense que c'est
un secret cruche c'était très mignon et
très hâte en mollissant donner envie de
nous qu est ce que vous prenez là pour
tenir le coup en allant la table de la
laitance de poissons tout simplement
et qu'est ce qui vous a donné ça amuse
toi non
[Musique]
le danger qui pouvait soupçonner qu'une
idée aux six un mécanisme de jeu aussi
le vous pouvez exiger autant de
préparation
[Applaudissements]